MAYBE TWO FBI INVESTIGATIONS
BECAUSE WE NEED TO KNOW.
THE ACLU HAS BEEN AROUND A LONG
TIME AND IT'S BUILT ITS
REPUTATION DEFENDING FREE SPEECH
AND ESPECIALLY DUE PROCESS
ESPECIALLY FOR THE POLITICALLY
UNPOPULAR.
IT SAVED THE LIVES AT THE
BEGINNING OF ITS EXISTENCE,
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
ACLU.
THOSE PRINCIPLES ARE BEING
WASHED AWAY IN THE TIDE OF
DERANGEMENT IN THE ACLU HAS
DECIDED TO JOIN THAT TIDE.
THEY ARE RUNNING AN AD DECLARING
HIM GUILTY WITHOUT THE NEED FOR
A TRIAL OR ANY EVIDENCE, WATCH.
>> WE SEEN THIS BEFORE, DENIALS
FROM POWERFUL MEN.
>> I DID NOT HAVE RELATIONS WITH
THAT WOMAN.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
>> I CATEGORICALLY AND
UNEQUIVOCALLY DENIED THE
ALLEGATION AGAINST ME.
>> AMERICA IS WATCHING AND AS WE
CHOOSE A LIFETIME SEAT ON OUR
HIGHEST COURT, INTEGRITY MATTERS
AND WE CANNOT HAVE ANY DOUBT.
SENATOR GARDNER, OPPOSE THE
CONFIRMATION OF JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
>> Tucker: CHRIS HAHN IS A
RADIO SHOW HOST, PROBABLY A
DONOR TO THE ACLU WHEN HE JOINS
US TONIGHT, IT'S GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
YOU ARE PUSHING LATE MIDDLE AGE,
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH
TO KNOW WHAT THE ACLU HAS BEEN
DOING.
>> LATE?
>> Tucker: WHATEVER.
YOU'RE PROBABLY OVER 30.
YOU'VE WATCHED THE ACLU OVER
TIME AND YOU KNOW THEY WERE
FOUNDED TO DEFEND FREE SPEECH
AND DUE PROCESS, A MAN IS GUILTY
ON THE BASIS OF NO EVIDENCE, HE
SHARES SOME RESEMBLANCE TO TWO
OTHER GUYS WHO ARE PROBABLY
GUILTY.
IT'S THE OPPOSITE OF DUE
PROCESS, WHY IS THE ACLU DOING
THIS?
>> THEY'RE NOT DECLARING HIM
GUILTY, WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO
AND GUILT OR INNOCENCE IS REALLY
NOT THE ISSUE.
HE'S NOT ON TRIAL FOR HIS LIFE
HE'S APPLYING FOR A JOB.
WE'VE GOT TO ASK THE QUESTION,
HAS HE BEEN TRUTHFUL IN THAT
INQUIRY IN THE ANSWER IS NO.
I DON'T KNOW FOR SURE ABOUT THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATION ALL
THAT AWAY           I
DO BELIEVE DR. FORD.
>> Tucker: BEFORE WE GET TO
WHAT YOU THINK HE SPECIFICALLY
LIED ABOUT I WANT TO REWIND
SECOND.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT WITHOUT
FINDING SOMEONE GUILTY OF
ANYTHING IT'S OKAY TO DESTROY
HIS REPUTATION TO THE POINT
WHERE HE CAN'T GET A PAYING WORK
AND CAN'T GET THE JOB THAT HE
WAS NOMINATED FOR BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE JUST HAS TO WITHDRAW AS A
LECTURER AT HARVARD BECAUSE HIS
REPUTATION HAS BEEN SO SULLIED.
HE HASN'T BEEN FOUND GUILTY OF
ANYTHING, BUT THAT'S OKAY WITH
YOU BECAUSE WE AREN'T IN A TRIAL
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
IS THAT THE NEW STANDARD?
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS YOU HAVE
TO ASK THE QUESTION IS THIS MAN
FIT FOR A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT
THAT WILL NEVER, EVER FACE THE
VOTERS, NEVER FACE CONGRESS
AGAIN.
IF YOU FEEL HE HASN'T BEEN
TRUTHFUL TO THAT COMMITTEE, I
WILL TELL YOU, I DON'T THINK HE
WAS TRUTHFUL.
>> Tucker: HE'S LIED, BUT
THAT'S UNPROVABLE.
IF YOU FEEL IN YOUR HEART -- IF
I FEEL IN MY HEART THAT YOU'RE A
CHILD MOLESTER, CAN I SAY THAT
ON TV AND SEE HOW IT AFFECTS HER
FAMILY?
>> I'M NOT TRYING TO GET A
LIFETIME APPOINTMENT ON THE
BENCH OF NO ONE IS ACCUSING ME
OF ANYTHING WHO DID NOT COME
FORWARD CREDIBLY.
>> Tucker: HE'S BEEN ACCUSED
OF A LOT OF THINGS, CREDIBLY IS
A SUBJECTIVE TERM.
IS IT OKAY IF YOU FEEL IN YOUR
HEARTS THAT SOMEONE IS GUILTY TO
SYSTEMATICALLY DESTROY HIM AND
HIS FAMILY AND YOU'RE SAYING
YES, IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
>> DID YOU FIND DR. FORD
CREDIBLE?
>> Tucker: I'M NOT SURE, SHE
WASN'T ASKED REAL QUESTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN DID YOU RECALL
THIS.
DID YOU TELL YOUR THERAPIST
ABOUT OF?
THAT'S A BASIC QUESTION NOBODY
ASKED.
>> YOU'RE SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE --
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
KNOW, THAT'S WHY I ASKED REAL
QUESTIONS ON MY SHOW.
>> I FOUND HER CREDIBLE AND I
THINK YOU FOUND HER CREDIBLE TO
TOO.
HE LIED ABOUT WHAT THE CLUB WAS,
HE LIED TO CONGRESS >> Tucker:
YOU'RE SAYING HE LIED ABOUT THE
RALPH CLUB?
YOU LIE ABOUT THE RALPH CLUB AND
YOU'RE DONE, I FEEL THAT IN MY
HEART.
THIS IS SO CRAZY.
>> WHY LIE ABOUT IT?
MY THING IS WHY LIE ABOUT THAT?
IT WAS SOMETHING HE COULD HAVE